[Music]
my guess this week is a filmmaker whose
documentary the red pill explores her
eye opening journey into the men's
rights movement which is out in select
theaters right now Cassie J welcome to
the Reuben report hello got a bigger
I've had a lot of people that have
wanted to make this happen
this sit-down I suspect that no matter
what we say over the next hour a certain
amount of people are going to love it no
matter what and a certain amount of
people are going to hate it no matter
what is that just part of talking about
men's rights and feminism does that just
come with the territory do you think ah
yes definitely I mean men's rights
especially just talking about men's
issues gets a lot of feathers ruffled
then that's partly why I wanted to make
the film yeah so let's talk about you a
little bit and your journey before we
get into the film specifically so tell
me a little about yourself were you
always interested in men's rights when
was your I know your revolution is
partly what happened during the course
of the film but you know just tell me a
little bit about growing up and that
kind of thing okay well I've I'm 30
right now I started making films when I
was 21 years old directing documentaries
and I've always been interested in
gender issues and sexuality so my first
film is about sex education in America
and it was called daddy I do and that
feature documentary really focused on
women's rights and women's issues
reproductive rights and single
motherhood and my second feature film
was about gay marriage called the the
right to love an American family and
that was released in 2012 and had great
response and positive reactions and then
in 2013 I was done screening the right
to love and I was looking for my next
topic and I was toying around with a
couple different film ideas one was
about the legalization of prostitution
issue or due to criminalization and I
was also looking at rape culture as
being a possible topic for my next film
and this was long before the hunting
ground came around and while I was
researching rape culture I came
across the online men's rights movement
and for about ten years previously I've
been a staunch feminist I'd been
interested in gender issues and
sexuality and I thought well what is
this hidden corner of the online
communities and is this the group of
misogynist I've been hearing him out
that are perpetuating rape culture and
so I embarked on this journey to make a
film about the men's rights movement but
from my feminist perspective yeah what
in your feminist perspective like how
would you summarize your version of
feminism at least before you started
this journey yeah uh well I I started
calling myself a feminist when I was
around 18 or 19 years old around
2004-2005 and at the time I was living
in Los Angeles and I when I started
telling my friends that I was a feminist
a lot of people were saying what your
women hater you're you're not a lesbian
you're you don't have hairy armpits and
so I had that you know that kind of it
back then it was still that old
mentality of thinking that feminists
were these butch lesbians kind of thing
and the reason I became a feminist was
because at the time I was acting in Los
Angeles I moved to LA when I was 18 and
started acting in a bunch of independent
films and and I was very green and naive
at the time and so I had a lot of
instances where film producers would
make advances on me and I felt like oh
so is this my role in the world is just
being this sexual object to be rather
than being uplifted for my talents or my
intelligence and and then a lot of the
roles that I was going out for and
acting were the hot blonde chick that
dies in the first 10 minutes and so I
was just fed up with you know this kind
of stereotypical role I was playing in
films and also it seems like in life and
so so that's interesting let's pause
there for a sec so somehow liberal
Hollywood is what pushed you into
feminism by its actual judgment of women
that's kind of interesting yeah yeah and
I mean I think a lot of girls in LA also
feel
justified for being a woman and and now
with making the red pill I have
different views on that but yeah and
also in the film industry it is the
statistics on how many women are
directors or producers or writers is you
know there's a big gap between men and
women in those positions so and so
definitely liberal Holly Hollywood I
think has just thinks a lot about
women's rights and women's issues and I
got you know wrapped up into that
culture and and also at the time as I
mentioned I started because 2004-2005
that was just when it was going or at
least I was going from my space to
Facebook and then later on Twitter came
around and tumblr and so I think during
this social media evolution feminism and
and what it was marketing as being a
feminist being the movement for gender
equality was kind of this easy pitch
it's like of course everyone should be
for gender equality and so so when
originally people were saying how are
you a feminist you're not a man-hater
kind of thing and then and I was telling
my friends that I was a feminist now
fast forward to 2013 when I started
looking at the men's rights movement all
my friends who were confused of why I
was a feminist now were more feminist
than I was and so I've definitely seen
this shift and people's acceptance of
feminism and accepting the label so you
were a card-carrying feminist so to
speak you find out about this men's
rights movement which was largely just
an online like what was it that you
first found out was these on message
boards or on where where were these
people when this thing started now it's
a little more it's gained a little more
traction I think it's out there a little
bit more but where was it at the time
yeah so at the time it was March 2013
and like I said I was researching rape
culture and then I stumbled across a
website called a voice for men calm and
whenever the men's rights movement is
talked about in mainstream media that
the few times it is talked about they
usually address a voice for men and
their misogynistic rantings and this
community of men who hate women and
share their hatred with each other and
and I'll get riled up together in this
online community of a voice for men
right so that was the website that I
initially found and I they definitely
have some crude language a lot of
swearing in there and a lot of talking
points that I never heard of before so
from my feminist perspective my walls
were up and I was immediately thinking
these are the misogynist I've been
hearing about and and it terrified me
and it took a couple months of me
looking at some other documentary topics
to explore and I just kept on coming
back to the idea of the men's rights
movement because I thought it was this
secret underwear underground world that
no one's ever explored and especially at
that time it not many people heard of
the men's rights movement so it really
interested me so your intentions when
you started were to look at this thing
and you saw the language they were using
at some of the overtop over-the-top
stuff and your intentions was sort of to
expose it through a documentary but your
feelings slowly change the more that you
got into it right yes yeah so when I
initially started I was thinking oh I'm
going to get great footage on camera
these guys you know ranting about women
or maybe even threatening me as I'm
interviewing them and and I did feel
like my protection while I was going to
interview men's rights activists where
was the camera as long as we're rolling
I'm okay with getting hurt and then and
you know also my having my crew there I
did feel protected but at the same time
I've been hearing that these men hey
women that they harassed women that they
Doc's women so that's what I was
expecting going into interviewing them
that I was going to see you know capture
this amazing footage of this yeah was it
hard to find people to interview because
I know the online especially in
something like a topic like this the
online world versus the actual world
sometimes have very little connection
with each other oh yeah I mean the
online world just you might as well be
oz behind the curtain I'm very in a
minute oh my gosh I can't even say that
word right there or not yeah anonymity
is comforting and people can act like
whoever they want to behind the computer
and and with the online men's rights
movement I think a
from what I've seen reading all the
comments and the articles that they
write there there is a lot of truth to
what they're saying although they do
take a less PC approach and so that's
what they're attacked for yeah from
mainstream media so what was like the
first issue that you saw them talking
about you thought oh there might be some
legitimacy here oh gosh well so for
context I films emerets and feminists
for a full year and I interviewed 44
people and each interview was different
from the next personality types some
drive very well and others I couldn't
quite connect with but each interview I
had we we went over all the issues and
and my understanding of each issue
evolved over that amount of time and
also watching the footage back and while
I was editing the film but domestic
violence was a big one that really got
me thinking just the amount of support
financial support emotional support
cultural support for female victims of
domestic violence versus men is
staggering and and then it won big a
turning point for me on my journey was
actually putting the magnifying glass on
my own feminist beliefs and realizing
that I was unwilling to have compassion
for a male victim of domestic violence
because I did interview some male
victims but if if it was a woman
speaking and she was saying the exact
same thing that this male victim was
saying then I would have had an instant
compassion without question or not
blaming her for the choices she made
whereas with these male victims I found
myself saying well why did you get into
this relationship with a woman who
obviously had a lot of red flags going
into it and why didn't you leave and so
so yeah well how much of that is just
male and women's stuff that's just
hardwired into us like the idea that the
man is supposed to be powerful and the
woman isn't now you have someone a man
that's being abused and
as you're saying it we sort of like
built into you to have less compassion
for them that's it's kind of tough to
untie that right yeah and and so often
within feminism we talk about double
standards that if you call a guy a
player or cool if he dates a lot of
girls and then a girl is sludd and so
within feminism we constantly talk about
double standards but then I ended up
seeing all these double standards within
within myself when addressing men's
issues and so as I was interviewing the
emerets men's rights activists I kept on
trying to find ways to diminish through
issues and I was first doing that myself
and also in my video diaries which are
included in the film but then once I got
past the point of making excuses for
these issues and was there a breaking
point I mean was there really a moment
where you were like I need to change my
own outlook here well you know I think
part of what gave me that breaking point
was when I started to explain to my
feminist friends men's issues that I
really did think had they had the
statistics to back them in the studies
and to support what the Emery's are
saying and so then I would try to relay
that message to my feminist friends and
then I saw their unwillingness to listen
and just be dismissive towards these
issues and I realized I was doing that
too but I did have a breaking point
where where I started thinking no we
should for instance let's use an example
with suicide 78% of all suicides around
the world are men and the common
reaction you'll get from feminists is
saying that more women attempt suicide
and I what I learned from the men's
rights movement is they aren't trying to
dismiss women's issues or they're not
saying that no woman has ever rape or no
women has ever abused by her spouse but
they're trying to bring up issues that
men face but when you do that instantly
feminists or even people who don't where
feminism on their sleeve but just are
the kind of mainstream liberal you know
right open seemingly open-minded person
over my today they used to be a theme
around
and stuff I talk about yes seemingly and
so they'll have these quick like
responses that are in essence
diminishing what the men's issue is like
saying well women more women attempt but
yes but still 78% of all suicides are
men yeah and then domestic violence one
in three women are within their lifetime
will be a victim of physical abuse by
intimate partner and one in four men and
that's from the CDC and it's very
similar we always hear about the one in
three women when talking about domestic
violence but we rarely hear about men so
so when you as when an MRA tries to
bring up one in four men immediately
feminists are saying yeah but more women
right okay but we talked about that and
why why are we so unwilling to address
men's issues what does that tell us do
you think about just our need to you
know I always talk about the oppression
Olympics here that everyone wants to be
more aggrieved than someone else so that
it seems like their problems are worse
and then by being more agree they're
somehow better then because it sounds
like that was a bit of the response you
were getting from the feminists you
weren't suddenly denying any of the
problems that feminists had right yeah
but you were saying here's some other
problems but for them it to acknowledge
that would somehow diminish their own
problems somehow I suppose in their mind
and that that's kind of crazy way to
have a whole conversation yeah and it
does turn into the tit-for-tat
oppression Olympics who's who has it
worse and that's what I found really
fascinating about making the red pill is
because emerets aren't dismissing
women's issues and all the Emery's I
spoke to said that they are for women's
rights that's a big misconception that
the mainstream media tries to paint
about the men's rights movement that
they're trying to turn back the clock on
women's rights when I'm back in the
kitchen barefoot pregnant and that's not
the case at all
and I would actually say they're even
going further into the gender equality
discussion by adding men to the
discussion and but what was so
fascinating about the just the feminist
ideology and that was a word that I
didn't connect with feminism many months
into filming and when it finally clicked
in my head that feminism is an ideology
and I love for our culture to get to a
point where we can distinguish between
and being for women's rights because
they are two different things feminism
is a movement with a belief system and
not all people who say there are
feminists or not all people who are non
feminists are against women's right so
you can be for women's rights without
being a feminist right so do you think
that the ideology of feminism or the
movement of feminism kind of lost its
way over the years do you think it's
possible I've had a few guests on here
that have said you know as things have
gotten better for women and as there is
equality for women you know you always
have to find a new oppression for
yourself according to this oppression
Olympics scale so you have to suddenly
be more offended by words if actions
aren't happening to you and things like
that so do you think the movement kind
of just lost its way uh I mean I'll try
to think back to my previous ten years
of being a feminist and how I saw it
evolve and I don't think when I became a
feminist around 2005 it wasn't as big as
it is now and I think social media has a
large part to do with that uh and it
it's almost gotten to the point where is
my personal opinion I don't think
everyone agree with this but it almost
becomes where people want to bully you
into labor labeling yourself a feminist
and I've heard some feminist women tell
men say well are you for gender equality
oh yes I am
I think you're a feminist and I and it's
almost like like a very if that's the
only you know test you have to take that
right are you for gender equality yes
and here's their score you're feminists
right
it's so much deeper than that and and it
is the politics of the movement is the
tactics it's the ideology that women all
women are oppressed by all men that we
live in a patriarchy and that's
discounting all the other factors
including gender roles that large part
of them are biologically related yeah
talk to me about the biologically
related gender roles because there is
something to that men evolved to be the
hunters and women where they gather is
there there is something there that
doesn't mean that obviously women can
have virtually any job that a man can
have and all that stuff but there there
are some things that have just weave
volved to be different right and that
that's okay yeah well I mean obviously
the how you bear children is is the
biggest difference and because women do
carry the child and also breastfeed that
does change how relationships the
dynamics of the home and how you operate
the home and raise the kids up that does
change who's decided to be the
breadwinner and if someone's going to
stay home who is going to be that person
and feminism has tried to rewrite the
script that the reason men go to work
and women stay home is because we had
this idea of the gender wage gap so
therefore washes she'd be the
breadwinner if she's going to be make 77
cents to a man's dollar that doesn't
make sense so it's keeping her in the
home because of this gender
discrimination but as I'm sure you know
the gender wage gap is not always right
we've dived into it yeah right how would
you actually define feminism and I
probably should have asked you this ten
minutes ago but what do you think the
actual what would your definition of
2016
what does feminism mean oh oh gosh I'm
really funny out of it yeah that's how
would I define feminism now with where
my head is after making the red pill uh
I I do believe it is an ideology and I I
actually came out of a religion when I
was in my teen years and uh spoiler
alert
with the red pill I also end up not
being a feminist after making the red
pill and they were very similar
experiences for me it it's I call it the
shedding process where it so happens
over a long period of years for me but
it's just resistance to wanting to hear
the facts and apply that to your belief
systems that's been so comfortable for
so long and that you've kind of blindly
believed in and led you throughout your
life and when you start questioning
that's very scary experience so but as
far as how I define feminism now I do
think of it as a quasi religion because
because the feminists that I've been
seeing are unwilling to have
a an intellectual discussion just based
on the statistics and facts that don't
fit within their belief system and so if
you believe that all when women are
oppressed by all men then how could it
be that women have more reproductive
rights and more reproductive choices
when having children and yet men could
be a victim of paternity fraud and
paternity fraud is when you're raising a
child that you later find out is not
yours and there's no repercussion for a
woman if she'd been lying to this man
for 18 years saying it's his own kid and
turns out it's not and the courts don't
support him being you know any any kind
of resolution to that I mean there's so
many different issues that do attack men
yeah and some of those things actually
are systemic like when people talk about
systemic racism there are things that
are systemic I have a friend right now
that's going through a divorce with the
child custody battle and he's been the
primary breadwinner for the entire time
at at times his wife didn't work and
didn't didn't have a lot of money and he
provided for everybody but she's getting
much more leniency related to the child
right now mm-hmm
that's actually systemic meaning that
it's part of the system the legal system
that she's getting benefits that that he
doesn't as a man yes yeah and you know
something when I was making the red pill
that was very interesting is that
feminists will also acknowledged custody
issues for men but they will still say
that it's discrimination against women
so the reason that women get custody of
the children about 80% of the time in
all custody cases is because it's
discrimination against women that women
are expected to be the child caretaker
and via the state if they get the child
which in most cases is what they want
that's still discrimination yes because
that's the role that the woman is
supposed to play yes yeah I just
recently I saw a video online about
maternity leave versus paternity leave
and it was something around the world
the average for maternity leave days
paid maternity leave days was 107
days around the world and for men it was
something like seven days and so they
said that statistic and then immediately
after they said this is discrimination
against women that were expected to take
care of the kids although the whole
video was talking about how the u.s.
needed maternity leave and paternity
leave yeah but yeah do you see some of
this stuff changing in a positive way I
have a friend who works at Facebook who
had his wife had a kid and they
basically like forced him to take
paternity leave like she was okay
handling it and she has a good family
that was around helping her with the kid
but they basically were like saying to
my friend no no you take it too and he
did and he ended up working from home a
lot and whatever but like so some of
this stuff is sort of evening out in
some ways right I yeah and something
don't have to yeah well I this I'm going
to steal a quote from Janis V man go his
professor at Ottawa University she says
that we need to strive towards equal
opportunity not equal outcome and I
think that you know applies with
maternity and paternity leave that we
should have equal opportunity for both
parents I and but we shouldn't force a
say um okay what's like an example we
shouldn't force girls to get into STEM
education so it equals to 50% or we
shouldn't force that we have half female
senators or CEOs and all that we
shouldn't force any of that and and I
think a lot of what Emma raised and
dissident feminists talk about is that
women do have choices actually more
choices than men do as far as if you
want to stay at home with the kids or be
a breadwinner and women are using that
choice and and so far it hasn't even
things out we don't have half the amount
of centers England so an artificial
quotas would just be artificial it
wouldn't necessarily mean that that's
exactly what women want to do or what
men want to do it would just be this
seems like it's fair it makes people
kind of feel good but it doesn't
actually mean that it's right or yeah
we're true you know it's something
that's interesting is that Michael Moore
is another
documentarian who's you know I really do
admire his work but he has a film
festival in Flint Michigan and his last
film festival he only accepted female
directed films and he said that he
wanted to do that until things become
even with female director films with
with men and how did that make you
you're with the line of work well I do
wonder if he told everyone that before
they submitted their film because if all
these guys are submitting their films
and they had no chance of making it to
the film festival that be little right
but but yeah I think it's very
interesting that there is this big push
to help female filmmakers although you
have to be on script because here I am a
female filmmaker and I have not gotten
the support that I've gotten from my
other films because this is not the the
red pill is not in line with the
feminist agenda and so doing a film
about feminism you're going to get a
certain amount of mainstream support
doing a film about gay rights you're
going to get a certain amount of
mainstream support this is the one where
as you said you're ruffling some
feathers so the mainstream support isn't
as easy so to speak and I would add that
that the amount of backlash that I've
seen from making this film I've been
it's been three and a half years now in
the making and we just released it last
week and because I haven't been seeing
that support of me making this film I've
started to realize that maybe feminism
is just it's not about feminism isn't
for women it's for feminism because if
it were just about women helping women
then I was a woman right right so and
and interestingly enough some some of
the most vocal people disagreeing with
my film or trying to actually wage a
smear campaign against me are one major
what I would call it a feminist troll
blogger David for trolleys male feminist
yeah and so it's just fascinating that
you know and there's so many people or
feminists who support his attacks on me
and it's just interesting gender
reversal yeah absolutely alright so
let's I want to back up the saying that
you said about the men's rights in the
first place that you didn't find there
to be that many
ah genius or guys that really hated
women or things like that you're not
saying that there are none right like
they're obviously there obviously are
some you're acknowledging that right
like I haven't met them really so you've
been when you were in the message boards
and things I haven't really dived in
that much to that kind of stuff but
really there wasn't like just some level
guys that are just angry maybe I read
the world and they're misdirecting it on
women or something else you really
didn't well there's really definitely
troll commenters but there is policing
happening on a voice for men and the
other men's rights websites and many
people would call him out or block them
from the site and and it's a great
example of what the mainstream media
will do with when reporting on the myth
reporting on the men's rights movement
is a Polly Lim who's the founder of a
voice for men there was someone who
wrote a horrible comment on a voice
fairness for about two years ago and so
and this was early on when they were
just really starting to grow and I was I
was filming them
so Paul Elam took this long horrible
common that was bashing women and
promoting violence against women and he
copied and pasted it into his article
and said this is absolutely unacceptable
if I see any of this activity you're
going to be blocked from the site and no
questions asked so it was just one
article that you wrote and copy and
pasted and then feminist media took the
comment that you quoted inside look at
what emerets and a voice for men says
about women and that was so common with
all the articles I was finding on voice
for men they do do a lot of satire and a
lot of the headlines are clickbait to
get you to think what what's that so for
instance a headline would be when is it
okay to punch your wife and but then you
read within it and and they are trying
to make a point all that you know with
right so their tactics maybe not the
best question more questionable
yeah but the content you're saying in an
article like that so what so in an
article I got when is it okay to hate
your life I would basically argue never
I guess if she could hit her back but
what in that type of article like what
yeah what are they going for well is
point is that there is this double
standard that you're not allowed to
defend yourself if you're a boy or man
and women can hit men that you can't hit
back and that's what the article talks
about and here's a good example of my
step nephew who's 15 years old who lives
in Seattle
just this past spring in at an assembly
at a school all of the boys had to get
off the bleachers go to the front of the
stage and take a pledge that they would
never hit a girl this is just a couple
months ago yeah and so this double
standard that boys can never hit girls
like girls you know free rein their
weight empowers girls to hit boys
probably at that school because they
know they're not going to be hit back
yeah that's a little weird did you see
this video maybe about two years ago on
the New York City Subway where this
woman was really berating this guy just
they didn't even know each other there's
on the subway some other random person
videotaping and she's screaming at him
screaming at his feet and finally she
hits him and he really was doing next to
nothing and then he did hit her back
basically knocked her out this was a big
guy and I did a video on it I basically
said and I've evolved a little bit with
all this stuff too but I basically was
like don't hit her he shouldn't hit her
he shouldn't hit her and I got a ton of
[ __ ] for that and in retrospect I guess
what I meant really was she hit you she
shouldn't have done it but you're a big
guy nothing good is going to come out of
this I guess in a situation like that
what do you think even because when
there are obvious strength differences
also now of course the strength
difference could be the other way you
could have a very meager guy in a and a
bodybuilding woman I mean all kinds of
things so I'm not even sure what my
question is about but what when you see
instances like that where the power
dynamic doesn't quite make sense for
what we think of yeah
anything he's trapped he's trapped
there's no easy answer people shouldn't
hit other people that's the end of it
but the system allows for women to hit
men without repercussions really and and
men cannot hit women or you're going to
jail and even just the accusation that a
man hit a woman or so many times I heard
from emerets that there would be some
kind of domestic violence situation in a
home where a woman is going out a guy
with a knife he grabs her arms to hold
her back
he leaves a couple bruises and he's the
one spending the night
and going to court but and I have heard
of so many of these cases of women
attacking men and and the strength issue
that something else that needs to be
brought into the discussion is that
women use weapons more often and so
there is an equalizer but it's hard you
know for that guy on the bus there's no
easy answer and you know because of the
culture we live in he's you know he's
going to be the one attack that he
shouldn't have done that and right and
then the end I wanted I guess my point
was just it sucks like she was abusing
him verbally she shouldn't hit him but
it was like nothing good was gonna come
out of it and yet at the same time it's
like she hit you like you can hit her
back it just feels weird I suppose but
that sort of is how the world works yeah
and I didn't include this in my film
because I couldn't find enough evidence
to prove this but one of the stories
that I heard while I was interviewing
ever emerets is that Rihanna with her is
a James Brown the ex Chris Brown yeah uh
yeah give her guys different her yeah
yes you know something that previous
life yeah so apparently when it was
first reported and this is just what an
Emer I told me I tried to find evidence
of this and I did find some articles
supporting what the samurai said but
that when I was first reported she was
wailing on him as he was driving and she
was attacking him he was swerving and
then he took one punch knocked her out
and then that was the infamous case of
her being beaten up and so I don't have
enough evidence to say that's exactly
true but if it were that I think that
should be talked about that what if it
wasn't just him slugging her out of
nowhere what if she was wailing on him
while he was driving he was swerving on
what place they were going to get into
crash and so whose fault is it but you
know the the women's movement and the
feminist movement really lifted up
Rihanna as this example of a female
victim of domestic violence and one of
the Emery's that she went back to him
also right and then they did a video
together and everything is sort of about
it and then a lot of feminist I guess
were against her or angry at her for
going back right yeah and that's the
thing with domestic violence is there
you know so many times you want to tell
the person who's who's saying their
victim or is actually a victim that they
need to make better choices get out of
that situation but you know there's a
lot more going on behind the domestic
violence issue than just all men abusing
women and nothing else no gray area
there's a lot of gray area
[Music]
you